[Music]
um this is a real quick one here Baba
real quick on Papa
uh Brandon Schaub
well first off what is up with his face
oh my God I wasn't is he all right I'm
not even saying to be a jerk
what's up with his face he looks weird
right it's been puffy
what is going on with him he's puffy and
he looks sad yeah well the set I get
and I don't want to get my security out
I don't want to get like he's wearing a
shirt from the Pitbull collection
who I roll without yeah because I got
people I mean I don't have people here
traffic in front of a five thousand
dollar UFC bet last year but I got
people if you need them right and
I was wondering how you want to get that
five thousand dollars to me let's enter
the uh the cash app the night once you
text me I said I didn't get it yeah
Allen has women ankles
wait a second hold on I didn't see that
yes I got it you sent it to me I sent it
now there's a limit on there so it's
going to come in that's what I mean now
here's the pro I knew it 2500 limit a
week I think with cash app is what he's
talking about I I yeah I need listen to
me no no no listen I get the money I'm
sorry am I the only one that
something's wrong with him something's
wrong with Brendan yeah he's on
something his face is like a [ __ ]
weird man what did you drinking and not
working out as much no he's not fat look
he doesn't have a gut it's not a gut
that's that's not now
just a touch of the consumption Bubba oh
okay so a little bit okay maybe I'm
scurvy not getting paid in increments
well the juice is running but here's
this is not his thing you're trying to
do double enough yeah something's going
on like the only the last time I saw
somebody's face like that was I remember
Nick Swardson when we saw him in that
movie and I was like why is his face so
oh yeah it was when he was partying a
lot yeah nothing right you don't want
that looks like a dog that ate a beer 10
G's you know what's been in five ten
hold on you know seven five I already
got some money in my account I said
Court you just told me you sent it did
you or did you that's what I'm saying
but we could do double enough on this
next one
you mean the rematch the Remake they're
gonna rematch they're not gonna
they're not gonna give Alex period like
you want me to break down I'll break
down well I was I was I was batting a
thousand on on Saturday I I had Poirier
for a lot of I'm sorry but that face is
someone who is strung out on some sort
of stimulant and is not sleeping right
like I I could only eats bad apparently
people are saying it might be like
anti-inflammatory steroids or something
maybe
what's in flame is [ __ ] brain
not so much a toss-up that first round
was yes yeah you're talking about a
crazy maybe like I just [ __ ] throwing
things to the wall he's developing like
a thyroid issue I mean he's getting
older
I mean maybe
that that dangerous could have been a
10-8 round yeah and I want to get your
tablet comes out like a band yeah I I
want to get your I want to get your
objective take off my assessment on
Chandler Poirier in a sec but I'm going
to say this about
this was like two seconds of bringing up
the bed I know I think they got and then
I you know they just try to throw so
many Clips in oh my okay here we go he
looked hold on a second it's really done
other people have no he looks really
dialed in now this man oh hold on hold
on I don't know what's so loud but hold
on here it is
dialed in but here's the thing you're
like man Brandon is zoned in but what is
going on with him then bags under those
eyes are getting heavy you can't you
know you Izzy he lost that fight he's
what what the firing all cylinders if
let's say and I don't stand there let's
say that he looks really dialed in well
no no no no no no no look at this
it's not just the puffiness because
here's puffy look at that fate what's
going on with you pal you all right
you're right what's going on Papa wait
of the world did someone else [ __ ]
out you for trying to make him give you
a [ __ ] in your F-150
um damn we gay huh you're ungrateful
bastard it seriously looks like Papa has
started tomorrow
I love the language of like the people
that fall out
look remember when when Colin had his
facelift it looked kind of like his role
model Brian Cowan on second thought
Rings looks so much better than Brenda
you know on a serious note of Papa's
many hilarious failures I think tiger
thick will end up being the most
damaging Endeavor both financially and
on his health this dude literally
ordered so much of this [ __ ] whiskey and
can't sell it so he's forced to do these
comedy tours to try and pedal it comedy
at the clubs but he can't even sell
tickets right now so basically now
Brendan is giving away free tickets to
his shows or canceling events and is he
really is that for real
oh [ __ ] he's left with all that sweet
necta which of course he has been
drinking non-stop it's seriously been
crazy to witness him scrambling to
correct his mouth I don't think he's
drinking whisk because he has too much
though there's something else that's not
the whiskey thing I mean it's a good
theory but I don't think so